Wir schauen auf die europäischen Top-Ligen und da gab es vor allem ein Thema, was dominiert hat, der Abschied von Jürgen Klopp. Aber das wird nicht das einzige sein, was wir heute besprechen mit Fabian Pakulat, Mario Rieker und Uli Hebel. Los geht's! Heute im Rasenfunk? Is magnificent!
Gamechanger.
Immer noch ein absoluter Banger, das Intro, auch wenn es bald gekürzt wird. Bitte schreibt mir keine Mails, es ist ein Ticken zu lang. Wir wissen es eigentlich alle, ich bin bloß noch nicht dazu gekommen. Aber darum soll es jetzt nicht gehen, sondern wir wollen sprechen über den Abschied von Jürgen Klopp Ich bin jetzt beim FC Liverpool. Uli, hat dich diese Meldung überrascht und was sind deine ersten Gedanken dazu gewesen?
Also der Zeitpunkt der Meldung und auch der Zeitpunkt des Austritts, der kommuniziert worden ist, der hat mich überrascht, dass er seit längerer Zeit darüber nachdenkt und auch das vereinsintern getan hat, irgendwann mal aufzuhören. Ja, ich habe eher mit Ende nächster Saison gerechnet. Das war so in etwa der Zeitpunkt, den wir auch immer im Podcast so gesagt haben, von dem wir ausgehen, dass es dann irgendwann zu Ende sein würde. Und meine ersten Gedanken dazu waren wahrscheinlich nicht die, die die allermeisten gehabt haben, auch schade und das Ende einer Ära und so quasi, ich muss jetzt einen Nachruf verfassen, sondern okay, was ist jetzt alles möglich mit der Truppe in diesem Jahr und logischerweise dann auch gleich direkt weiter. Wie wird es dem Verein denn danach gehen? Weil in erster Linie übergibt er einen gesunden Verein, eine tolle Mannschaft in einer guten Altersstruktur mit weitreichenden Verträgen, minus jetzt vielleicht drei Leuten, das werden wir dann sicherlich auch noch darüber sprechen, aber alles in allem allerbeste Voraussetzungen in der komplett ersten Sichtweise. Und in der zweiten haben wir jetzt gelernt, gerade in englischen Konstrukten sind Manager, die so lange gewirkt haben und so dominant gewirkt haben und die auch Sportdirektoren und andere Fahnensträger überlebt haben, ganz oft so stark und so vereinzelt, dass es gar nicht so leicht ist, dass man dann den Verein hinterherführt, erfolgreich weiterführt und vielleicht gar nicht einfach einen nur anknüpfen kann. Das ist irgendwie immer noch was, wo ich immer noch nicht genau weiß, wie es weitergeht. Es war bei der im Hintergrund immer noch die Idee, zumindest der Fenway Sports Group, eventuell zu verkaufen. Es hört sich jetzt im Moment alles ganz anders an, aber hing das mit rein. Also ich könnte jetzt noch ewig so weitermachen, weil logischerweise war das jetzt auch in meinem Leben durchaus präsent, die ganze Nummer. Ich habe es bis dahin aber geschafft, mich nicht dazu zu äußern. Das ist Part 1, sonst ist nichts passiert.
Aber heißt das, Uli, glaubst du wirklich sozusagen, dass obwohl er jetzt die Mannschaft wieder so gut hingestellt hat, ich meine, die letzten Jahre waren vielleicht auch mal ein paar nicht so erfolgreiche dabei, dass diese Einzelperson, der abgang, so einen Kollaps auch bedeuten könnte?
Ja, möglich. Also stand jetzt steht Liverpool ohne Führungsmannschaft da. Kein Manager, also im klassischen deutschen Sinne kein Manager, kein Trainer, keinen übergeordneten Director of Football. Und selbst da ist ja die ganze Zeit gewechselt worden auf der Position. Und dann eventuell noch eine Besitzergruppe, die verkaufsbereit ist. Das ist jetzt wahrscheinlich für Van Dijk, für Salah, für Trent Alexander-Arnoldi, weil sie jetzt noch eineinhalb Jahre Verträge haben. Und bei Salah wird es eh, fürchte ich darauf hinauslaufen, dass er nach Saudi-Arabien geht. Vielleicht auch ganz okay zu dem Zeitpunkt, dass man dann noch Geld verdient mit ihm. Also möglich, dass die erstmal in so ein 2, 3 Jahre Sinnloch fallen. Das würde mich nicht komplett wundern.
Kommt drauf an, wer kommt wahrscheinlich, ne? Mit wie viel Energie? Xavi Alonso zum Beispiel ist ja genannt worden. Wäre er schon eine Geschichte, der das ganz gut vielleicht auffangen könnte mit seiner Geschichte bei Liverpool und so?
In der Theorie, ja. Ich bin nicht so glücklich mit Xavi Alonso. Und dass der als zweite Station – man muss sich ja immer vorstellen, in England ist es ja inzwischen – das heißt inzwischen, das sage ich immer so, aber das ist nicht leichter geworden in den letzten Jahren mit medialer Präsenz und so was. Du bist nicht nur Fußballtrainer und mit allem Respekt für Leverkusen und die Menschen, alle vier, die sich dafür interessieren, was da passiert in dem Verein medial.
Mit allem Respekt aber.
Das ist eine komplett andere Wucht, die Liverpool entwickelt. Eine ganz, ganz andere Welt. Ich habe vor Ewigkeiten – ich hoffe, ich darf das jetzt einfach mal so sagen, aber Moritz Folz war ja bei Arsenal als Spieler unterwegs und ich habe ewig mit ihm damals diskutiert, wer denn Wenger nachfolgen würde und so. Ich habe gesagt, ey, Eddie Hauer muss mir doch eine Chance geben und das wäre doch ein guter Trainer und dann müsste man halt einfach mal zwei, drei Jahre durchladen. Das ist ja kein Problem. Und dann stünde man da mit einem tollen Fußballlehrer. Da habe ich mich ausgelacht und gesagt, das geht nicht. Wie sollst du denn den Jahreskarteninhabern klar machen, wir machen jetzt mal zwei, drei Jahre Reload, nachdem du den haben sie ja schon gemacht vor Klopp unfreiwillig in Liverpool mit Roy Hodgson und wie sie alle hießen, die ganzen Experimente, die vorne und hinten nicht funktioniert haben. Sir Kenny Doglish, der jetzt in den höchsten Tönen gelobt wird als Trainer. Ich weiß nicht, ob die alle jemals ein Fußballspiel von ihm gesehen haben, aber ich leider ja. Deswegen glaube ich jetzt nicht, dass er nie mehr als ein Interimstrainer in seiner zweiten Amtszeit war. Deswegen weiß ich nicht, ob man auch Xavi Alonso da mit so einem riesengroßen Gefallen tun würde. Also Arteta, von dem ich sehr, sehr viel halte bei Arsenal. Das hat so lange gedauert, bis der reingefunden hat in die ganze Nummer. Und Medial tut das, finde ich, immer noch nicht so ganz. Also der bespielt nicht all das und man muss nur mal bei Marco Rose nachfragen oder bei allen anderen Dortmund-Trainer, wie es ist, auf Jürgen Klopp zu folgen. Ich hätte lieber ehrlich gesagt jemanden, à la Thomas Frank von Brentford, mit dem sich Liverpool, das weiß ich, schon seit Jahren unterhält. Also die sind in Kontakt miteinander. Der wird nie genannt, medial, aber das weiß ich, die sind in Kontakt miteinander. Das würde mir besser gefallen, weil das jemand ist, der in seinem ganzen Leben für sich verstanden hat, dass man ein Umfeld unterhalten muss. Also dass man so eine Art Supervisor zu sein hat in England. Der hat das auch minutiös gelernt. Das hat auch nicht von Anfang an so funktioniert in Brentford. Mir ist auch klar, das ist ebenfalls komplett andere Welten medial gesehen. Aber der kommt damit schon sehr, sehr gut klar. Das wäre jetzt für mich so, wenn man das vorbereitet im Gesamtkonstrukt, jemanden, der es mir im Moment besser gefallen würde. Ich will nicht, Xavi Alonso, um Himmels willen nicht falsch verstehen, das wissen wir glaube ich alle. Das scheint ein sehr fähiger Fußballtrainer zu sein.
Ja, der kann ja auch erst zu Barca und dann zu Liverpool. Das ist doch easy. Vielleicht ist der Schritt zu Liverpool noch zu groß. Da geht er jetzt erstmal zu Barca.
Barca ist ja easy, genau. Da kann er in die Leere gehen und dann kann er rüberkommen.
Zwei Gedanken dazu. Ich weiß voll, was du meinst mit Leverkusen. Das ist was anderes. Ich glaube, Stichwort Komfortzone. Rudi Völler hast den Begriff. Auf der anderen Seite aber, glaubst du wirklich, dass es für die gerade von dir angesprochenen Jahreskarteninhaber in Xavi Alonso so ein Reload-Trainer wäre, allein von der Aura her. Wobei wiederum, ich sag mal, der große Unterhalter ist er auch nicht. Ich durfte ja auch schon mal mit ihm an der Seite die Interviews machen.
Ja, auf romantischer Ebene ist es klar, dann haben wir es eingeloggt und nehmen alles das. Aber das Gleiche kann man ja auch über Real Madrid und Bayern München sagen, bei Xavi Alonso theoretisch. In der Theorie ja, funktioniert es. Ich glaube einfach, selbst dieses eine Jahr Champions League in Weber-Cousins, das sie spielen werden, würde ihm sehr guttun. Das hat er alles noch nicht gemacht und das kriegt in der Premier League einfach andere Züge. Du misst dich dann direkt mal mit Pep Guardiola. Und das viermal im Jahr, wenn es gut läuft für den eigenen Klub. Das heißt, ich bin ganz so überzeugt wie alle, dass es jetzt schon, auf jeden Fall, das wird passieren und das wird dann auch total erfolgreich und super. Das stellen wir uns halt zuvor, weil der halt da mal gespielt hat und weil es sehr romantisch klingt. Und wir wollen ja immer auch, also wenn vor eineinhalb Jahren, wenn wir hier zusammengekommen hätten und gesagt hätten Jürgen Klopp tritt zurück, dann hätten alle gesagt, Steven Gerrard muss es machen. Schlecht gealtert.
Wobei wir natürlich auch wissen, ich bin auch großer Fan davon, irgendwie Tränen länger Zeit zu geben, auch für ihre Entwicklung, auch bei einzelnen Vereinen. Es gibt immer Vereine, bei denen das gut funktioniert. Wir wissen aber auch alle, dass, und das vielleicht auch bei den Einzelpersonen selber so der Fall, dass in der schnelllebigen Branche der Reflex, wenn sich irgendwo die Tür auf, wenn die aufgeht, da durchzugehen, der ist schon gegeben.
Du hast halt bei Xavi Anunza noch den kleinen Unterschied zu Steven Gerrard oder wie auch immer. Der hat halt schon bei Liverpool gespielt, der hat halt schon, also bei Steven Gerrard natürlich auch, aber der hat auch bei Real Madrid gespielt, hat auch bei Bayern gespielt. Der weiß schon, wie Champions League geht, der weiß schon, was Druck ist. Der ist medial mit Sicherheit, nicht auf dem Level eines Klops, keine Frage, aber rein von der Erfahrung her, obwohl er es als Trainer nicht hat, aber als Spieler hat er schon einiges mitgemacht, Weltmeister geworden und so weiter. Also da würde ich ihm schon zutrauen, dass er das als Trainer auch managen kann, dann irgendwie zumindest stimmungsmäßig innerhalb des Teams, dass er das wirklich auch verkaufen kann, was da jetzt auf dem Spiel steht. Das glaube ich schon, medial bin ich bei dir Uli, da ist er mit Sicherheit.
Ich würde gar nicht jetzt nur Medien überinterpretieren wollen, weil es gibt auch andere Trainer, dann ist das völlig wurscht und das funktioniert auch. Und auch in England im Übrigen.
Also Pep Guardiola ist jetzt auch nicht irgendwie ein Stand-up Comedian.
Aber was Pep Guardiola außerordentlich gut macht, ist den gesamten Verein und das ist ja wirklich ein sehr viel größeres Unternehmen, dieser Verein Liverpool inzwischen, als es Leverkusen ist. Das ist ja der große Vorteil, den Leverkusen hat, dass da drei, vier, fünf Leute miteinander sprechen. Die sind alle wahnsinnig sachverständig, aber die sprechen halt miteinander und ganz, ganz selten mit uns. Das ist ja deren großer Vorteil. Deswegen sind die ja so gut, weil die wirklich eng beieinander sein können. Und das ist ja nicht Leverkusens Fehler, dass sich nur vier Leute dafür interessieren, sondern ich finde es erstaunlich, dass sich bundesweit immer noch kein Mensch für Leverkusen interessiert. Immer noch nicht. Immer noch nicht. Obwohl die sensationell gute Arbeit leisten und man gerade den hinteren Teil, also alles, was hinter Xavi Alonso ist, mal abbilden sollte. Aber anderes Thema. Nicht für die Ligatur zumindest. Und das ist aber mein Punkt, dass ich mir nicht sicher bin, wie schnell könnte Xavi Alonso da reinwachsen, ein Enterprise zu bespielen und zu befrieden. Und es ist ja nicht so, dass das alles unter Jürgen Klopp die ganze Zeit über ruhig war, beileibe nicht. Das hat man in Deutschland nur nie mitbekommen. Aber die Kämpfe mit Michael Edwards als Sportdirektor, bis er jetzt seinen Jörg Schmattke installiert bekommen hat, interimistisch und so. Das waren echte Kämpfe für Klopp, dass er überhaupt die Macht bekommen hat, in diesem Verein so wirken zu können, wie es jetzt tut. Das war in den ersten eineinhalb Jahren völlig undenkbar. Und all diese Dinge, die musst du inzwischen als Fußballmanager in England ja auch können. Insbesondere bei einem der wahrscheinlich immer noch zwei größten Klubs, was das mediale Interesse betrifft. Und das als zweite Trainerstation nach eineinhalb Jahren Wirken in Leverkusen direkt zu machen. Ich traue es ihm fachlich zweifellos zu. Ich glaube auch, dass der Typ die Persönlichkeit dazu hat, grundsätzlich eines Tages mal da in der Seitenlinie zu stehen. Vielleicht funktioniert es auch sofort. Vielleicht ist er einer derjenigen, von denen man denkt, na ja, kein Problem, nahtloser Übergang für ihn von Leverkusen nach Liverpool. Aber ich möchte das nur laut zu bedenken geben. Das ist nicht dieselbe Liga. Und es sind nicht mal zwei dazwischen oder drei oder vier, sondern Liverpool ist ein Weltkonzern. Und das ist Leverkusen nicht. Und ich glaube, da trete ich wirklich niemandem zu nahe, egal wie ich es formuliere.
Na, der Konzern an sich schon, ne?
Oder Punkt.
Aber der hat sich ja noch nie was zu Schulden kommen lassen, wenn ich das richtig verfolgt habe. Der muss ja noch nie mit Kritik umgehen. Aber Uli, wie würdest du denn dann gewichten? Sportliche Ausrichtung des neuen Trainers und eben all das, was du jetzt gesagt hast. Also eben Führungsqualitäten, Außendarstellung und so weiter und so fort. Weil das wäre ja auch ein krasser Wechsel. Also als Jürgen Klopp damals kam, kam er in eine ganz andere Liga rein eigentlich und hat ja auch eigene Elemente mitgebracht. Aber wenn wir jetzt über Xavi Alonso sprechen oder über andere Trainer, dann sind das ja auch sehr unterschiedliche Stile.
Ja, ich glaube, Letzteres und das haben wir jetzt lange besprochen ist Grundlage dafür, dass man sportlich machen darf, was man will. Die Truppe ist jetzt so zusammengebaut. Ich meine, die ist ja ehrlicherweise jetzt im Sommer so umgebaut worden, dass es mehr denn je die Truppe ist oder die Spielart, die Klopp ganz zu Beginn gespielt hat. Also so 17, 18er Fußball.
Also wieder Gegenpressing und so weiter.
Genau. Sehr, sehr viel mehr Gegenpressing. Die sind sehr, sehr viel schneller direkt an den Leuten, wenn die ihre Bälle verlieren. Sie sind aber selbst auch schneller in Drucksituationen als in den letzten vier, fünf Jahren wieder. Sie sind direkter auch in aller Regel. Das ist der einzige Kritikpunkt, den ich an der Spielweise noch habe, dass sie mir manchmal zu wenig kontrolliert sind und dass es dann zu sehr auf dem 4-3 hinauslaufen könnte, obwohl sie es eigentlich mit 2-0 bespielen müssten. Ich glaube aber, dass du als neuer Trainer, all diese Sachen, das kann auch positiv sein. Das muss man jetzt nicht falsch verstehen. Man kann jetzt sagen, es ist eine wahnsinnige Last und es ist ein weißes Blatt Papier mehr oder weniger mit halt einem sensationellen Kader. Es kann natürlich auch so sein, dass man hergeht und sagt als neuer Trainer, cool, hier gibt es keinen Sportdirektor, sondern ich bin hier der starke Mann, weil die wollen mich unbedingt und jetzt baue ich mir mal mein Umfeld so zusammen und habe ja schon den Kader für das, was ich hier brauche. Vielleicht noch links und rechts, da sollte das Geld dafür vorhanden sein. Wenigstens hätte die Fan-Way-Sports-Group, so hört man ja auch Klopp, nochmal überreden wollen mit viel, viel Transferbudget im Rahmen der Financial Fair-Play-Regeln. Aber wenn der neue Trainer das bekommen würde, kann das auch so sein. Aber um die Frage nach der Gewichtung zu beantworten, so hässlich das klingt, aber das muss mindestens 40, 60 sein. Also, dass du der Supervisor bist in diesem Verein. Andernfalls, glaube ich, wird es dir speziell im Abgleich dann mit deinem Vorgänger relativ schnell um die Ohren fallen.
Ja, ich finde es halt insofern interessant, weil damals als Klopp dorthin gewechselt ist. Da gab es ja dann viele Geschichten darüber, dass ja quasi das auch so ein datenzentrierter Wechsel war. Also, dass sich die Datenabteilung von Liverpool, so wie sie Spieler scouten, auch Trainer gescoutet haben und dann eben Klopp auf der Liste stand und sie deswegen auch eben nicht irritiert waren von dieser Horror-Halbserie mit Dortmund, wo man ja nach Expected Goals und so weiter an ganz vielen Daten sehen konnte. Meine Güte, da kam auch wirklich alles am Pech zusammen, was man haben kann. Plus irgendwann hat sich dann es verselbstständigt und deswegen haben die das ja auch so ein bisschen durchgedrückt nach den Artikeln, die ich gelesen habe. Weil es gab ja durchaus auch Leute, die gesagt haben, ist das jetzt wirklich der richtige, der normal one, der dann kam. Und das finde ich schon interessant, weil das scheint ja so ein bisschen dem zu widersprechen, was du jetzt gerade sagst, was man eigentlich braucht. Weil dann sind ja quasi nur die 40 Prozent damit abgedeckt, nämlich quasi das, was man auf dem Spielfeld sehen kann.
Ja, vielleicht werden sie es auch komplett anders machen. Vielleicht gehen sie auch her und machen in Liverpool genau das, was sie immer gemacht haben. Und dann würde ich aber tippen, dass es eher auf Roberto de Zerbin auslief, dass sie den mal anfragen würden.
Sebastian Hoeneß habe ich auch gelesen in einem analytischen Medium. Ich glaube, thealadist.com hat eine Analyse gemacht und Sebastian Hoeneß als einen perfekten Fit hinbekommen. Und da dachte ich mir auch, ja, also fußballerisch kann ich mir das super vorstellen.
Nehmen wir mal Xabi Alonso und die Spielerkarriere weg und vergleichen nur mal die Trainer Hoeneß und Xabi Alonso miteinander, dann würde ich sagen, ja, da würde ich wahrscheinlich sogar lieber den Hoeneß nehmen, weil der hat schon zwei Sachen mehr hinter sich. Ich bin echt auch gespannt, was sie machen, ob sie eine Kopie suchen. Kann ja auch sein, da würde wahrscheinlich sogar Thomas Frank am ehesten hinkommen als so ein potenzieller Kult-Trainer, also um dieses dämliche Wort Kult mal zu benutzen, aber so jemand, in dem man sich glaube ich sofort verliebt, wenn der an der Seitenlinie da ist, weil der einfach sofort versteht, was im Verein los ist. Das wäre ja wahrscheinlich am ehesten eine Art Kopie von Klopp oder versuchen sie es eben mit dem Gegenteil. Das würde dann wieder total für Xavi Alonso sprechen, wenn nüchternen Analytiker dem wurscht ist, ob die da an der Enfield Road total unterhalten sind, wenn er denkt, dass wir das Zentrum zumachen wie im ersten Halbjahr in Leverkusen. Ja, dann machen wir es halt, weil das bringt den Erfolg. Ich bin selbst total gespannt und die Wahrheit über alt ist ja und deswegen ist es ja so erstaunlich. Erstens kam es ohne großen Anlauf daher und zweitens haben wir es ja noch nie erlebt. Also dieser FC Liverpool, als Klopp den übernommen hat, also ich sage das jedes Mal beim Crystal Palace Spiel, wenn ich das mache gegen Liverpool, wie weit die gekommen sind, weil da gegenüber Roy Hodgson steht und da waren sie das 17. und da haben Leute wie Warnock gespielt und Fabio Aurelio und solche Granden. Und heute musst du dir überlegen, ach, Gagbo kommt nur von der Bank. Naja, okay. Und wir überlegen uns jetzt, die Innenverteidiger, da würde ich mir aber mehr wünschen, weil das ist halt nur Konate. Und das haben wir ja alles so noch nicht erlebt bei Liverpool. Also diesen Aufstieg, den ja auch Klopp total mit zu verantworten hat, hin und zurück zu dieser Weltklasse und zu diesem Riesenkonzern, den kennen wir ja so nicht. Und das heißt, wir wissen gar nicht, wie die FanRace Sports Group auf diesem Level reagiert auf irgendwas. Wahrscheinlich werden sie jetzt nicht verkaufen, weil das ist eines der wichtigsten Assets, das ist ja weg beim Verkauf. Auch alles, was ich jetzt so gehört habe in den letzten paar Tagen, ist, dass sie fürs Erste durchziehen wollen. Aber auch das spielt ja noch mit rein. Also würden die jetzt vielleicht sagen, okay, dann wollen wir jetzt auch nicht mehr, weil das ist für uns dann auch viel zu anstrengend. Ich habe auch immer gedacht, dass das eventuell mit rein spielt in der Klop-Entscheidung, dass das ja sein absoluter Intimus da in der FanRace Sports Group gegangen ist vor, ich glaube, jetzt zwölf Monaten circa. Er sagt aber öffentlich, und dann will ich ihm das auch glauben. Nein, das ist auf keinen Fall so, sondern das war einfach nur eine Entscheidung fürs Privatleben oder aus dem Privatleben heraus. Dann möchte ich das auch so glauben, aber das sind alles so Stränge. Ihr merkt jetzt schon, ich habe echt noch nicht darüber gesprochen, deswegen sammelt sich das alles. In diesem Podcast sind alles so Stränge, die mit rein spielen.
Aber wenn man nochmal auf die Anfangszeit von Klopp zurückblickt, weil du das jetzt auch gerade gemacht hast, dann sieht man ja also Brandon Rogers, das war die Saison 14, 15, da sind sie 6. geworden, Jürgen Klopp kam, sie sind 8. geworden und erst im darauffolgenden Jahr zum 1. Mal 4. oder nochmal 4. und dann kam der Zug so langsam ins Rollen. Glaubst du, dass – obwohl jetzt natürlich Liverpool aus einer anderen Situation kommt – aber dass das vielleicht einem möglichen Nachfolger ein bisschen mehr Zeit gibt, weil die Fans das schon mal erlebt haben, dass es eben Zeit braucht?
Weil dafür ist der Kader zu teuer und zu gut und das wissen auch alle. Die Zeiten, glaube ich, in denen man Zeit hat, um anzukommen in einem Premier League Club dieser Größenordnung, sind komplett vorbei. Es ist eigentlich erstaunlich, dass Arteta immer noch an der Seitenlinie steht. Ich kann mir das beim besten Willen nicht vorstellen, dass irgendein Trainer mehr als ein halbes Jahr Zeit bekommt, um anzukommen. Wenn es dann nicht mindestens um die Champions League Qualifikation geht, dann ist der wieder weg. Da bin ich mir eigentlich ziemlich sicher.
Ja, gut. Ich meine, irgendwie unter den 4 müsste man ja auch noch landen. Andererseits, wenn ich mir die Tabelle so angucke, eigentlich auch nicht.
Das Problem ist ja, das ist ja auch generell etwas, das über der Abendzeit Klopp steht. Man könnte jetzt sagen, er ist endlich mal wieder Meister geworden. Oder man sagt, er ist nur einmal Meister geworden mit all dem, was in dem Kader drinsteckt. Das ist aber kontextabhängig, wie man es bewertet. Weil in diesem Kontext würde ich jedem sagen, ja, aber – und das aber heißt Manchester City.
Genau.
Und das ist halt auch gar nicht so leicht, gegen die Meister zu werden. Und wenn du halt gerade gegen Manchester City gut performst – das haben sie ja meistens gemacht – dann gibt es halt ein Team, das überperformt hat, wie Chelsea. Also das konnte Chelsea von damals, als die Meister geworden sind, als Liverpool das hätte machen müssen. Oder halt Leicester, mit dem niemand gerechnet hat. Das wäre ja auch eine Möglichkeit gewesen für Liverpool damals. Und du spielst halt – also die Wahrheit ist ja, die Konsolenspielerinnen und Spieler unter euch, die werden das wissen. Wenn man in der Premier League spielt, bei FIFA zum Beispiel, dann spielst du jedes zweite Wochenende gegen ein Team, gegen das du echt zusammenreißen musst, wenn du auf Weltklasse-Niveau spielst, also auf dem Level Weltklasse. Wohingegen, wenn du in Frankreich spielst oder in Spanien, also no front, aber dann spielst du halt mal gegen Grenada, ja passt schon, dann spielst du halt mal gegen Las Palmas, R4-0, alles gut. Aber das geht halt in England nicht. Da ist inzwischen die Dichte so hoch, dass du brauchst auch zwei volle Bandschaften, um das alles durchziehen zu können. Plus zwei Pokalwettbewerbe, plus dann ja noch Europapokal. Das ist eben die Frage auch nach der Bewertung, wie man diese Amtszeit nimmt. Und das wiederum führt aber dann zurück auf eben genau das, dass ich nicht denke, dass irgendjemand bei Liverpool noch mal Zeit bekommt. Im Gegenteil, ich glaube, die haben so Angst, dass sie runterfallen von diesem Status, dass sie noch schneller reagieren würden als andere.
Boah, würde ich dann vielleicht gar nicht machen wollen. Aber dann um nochmal kurz, also nicht, dass sie mich anfragen, lasst es. Ost hat hiermit dementiert. Der macht es nicht. Aber um nochmal kurz auf Jürgen Klopp dann zurückzukommen. Du hast es ja gerade schon angesprochen, diese Dualität mit Manchester City. Und Pep Guardiola hat sich ja sehr, da hatte er wieder so einen persönlichen, starken emotionalen Moment, als er auf Jürgen Klopp angesprochen wurde. Und gleichzeitig hat er aber auch ein vergiftetes Kompliment mitgegeben, weil er gesagt hat, unser Run oder unsere Stärke wäre nicht möglich gewesen ohne ihn. Und da steckt da quasi auch schon das drin, was du gesagt hast. Man kann es positiv lesen, kann sagen, was war das für ein geiler Fight, den Jürgen Klopp, Pep Guardiola und diesem Milliardenprojekt Manchester City geliefert hat. Man kann aber auch sagen, war es nicht irgendwie ein langweiliger Fight, weil es ja Manchester City die ganze Zeit gewonnen hat.
Ja, also auch von mir aber ein persönlicher Dank an beide, weil das war wirklich wunderbar. Also diese Duelle waren echt stark und ich dachte eigentlich schon, die sind tot letzte Saison, aber here we go. Es ist eine definierende Ära in der Premier League, tatsächlich. Diese beiden gegeneinander, dieses Duell Rot gegen Hellblau, das war schon immer was Besonderes. War übrigens auch mein erster Gedanke, ich habe City noch mal gemacht auf der Zone, ich glaube beim FA Cup, und es war mein allererster Gedanke, dass Goldiola sich denken wird, endlich ist der weg. Das ist glaube ich die Art und Weise, mit der er am wenigsten gut zurecht kam. Adheta ist ja quasi sein Klon, ich glaube damit kommt er klar, dass man einfach auf dem Schachbrett die Läufer verschiebt. Das ist alles easy für ihn.
Aber Klopp hat auch eine Axt mitgebracht zum Schachbrett.
Genau, aber dieses emotionale, das unfeuerartige, wo du nicht weißt, was genau passiert, das glaube ich hat ihn schon öfter mal wachgehalten. Den anderen, mit dem kommt er einigermaßen klar. Jetzt habe ich ganz vergessen, wie die Frage war, aber vielleicht war schon was drin von dem, was du jetzt meintest.
Es geht quasi jetzt um die Bewertung der Zeit von Jürgen Klopp bei Liverpool. Und ich will das jetzt gar nicht schlecht reden und so weiter, aber das gehört ja irgendwie fast schon so zu Tragic mit dazu. Also er ist – ich weiß nicht, wie Mario und Fabian das sehen – aber wahrscheinlich ist er der größte oder einer der größten deutschen Trainer – das sowieso. Und das ist ja immer so ein bisschen seltsam, wenn man so etwas quasi live erlebt. Weil es gibt dann immer so Momente, da erkennt man das so langsam. Also Jürgen Klopp, er macht bei Mainz eine gute Arbeit, er kommt zu Borussia Dortmund, braucht ein bisschen dann diese zwei Meisterschaften. Man denkt sich, oh krass, der ist ja gut, der ist ja super in der Außendarstellung. Manchmal auch ein bisschen pumpig. Ich will jetzt gar nicht sagen, hier alles ganz toll bei Jürgen Klopp, aber ja schon ein besonderer Trainer. Dann wechselt er zu Liverpool. Man denkt sich, boah, das könnte richtig gut werden, aber bisher hat man halt deutsche Trainer meistens scheitern sehen. Der Käse und Felix Magert, wobei das ja glaube ich erst später kam. Aber das ist ein Beispiel dafür. Und dann sieht man aber, ach krass, das funktioniert da auch. Und dann irgendwann, ich weiß nicht, ist es dann der Champions-League-Titel 2018, 19, ist es schon vorher, wo man einfach auf Augenhöhe mit Manchester City ist. Aber dann erkennt man, krass, das ist ja wirklich ein wahnsinnig guter Trainer. Und dann wechselt das so ein bisschen. Ich weiß nicht, Mario, wie du zum Beispiel auf die Zeit von Jürgen Klopp und seine Person auch blickst.
Also ich habe mir jetzt auch die letzten zwei Tage ein bisschen Gedanken darüber gemacht, was ich zu ihm überhaupt sagen kann. Als erstes ist mir so ein Kopf gekommen, naja, wir werden ihn auf jeden Fall jeden Tag noch irgendwo in der Werbung sehen. Wir müssen ihn nicht so sehr vermissen über das Jahr.
Er wird nicht weg sein. Vor allem in englischsprachigem Medien macht er ja noch für ganz andere Sachen Werbung, habe ich jetzt gesehen bei irgendeiner Champions-League-Frauen-Übertragung. Genau, da sitzt er doch auf einem Home-Trainer und ist genauso sympathisch wie immer.
Ja, und dann ist mir so in den Kopf gekommen, die persönliche Entwicklung, die er genommen hat, wie ich finde, eine positive. Ich habe ihn viel erlebt. 2012 zu seiner Dortmunder-Zeit, da war ich fünf Wochen als Volumptär bei Sky, Reporter Stefan Schäuble, liebe Grüße an der Stelle, unterwegs und habe ihn wirklich da jeden zweiten Tag auf die PK gegangen, am Trainingsplatz. Und du hast gerade einmal so, weiß nicht welches Wort du genutzt hast für seinen Umgang mit Journalisten. Pampik, ich fand ihn teilweise damals wirklich daneben. Also es war eine Zeit, wo er nicht mein Lieblingstrainer war. Ich finde, da hat er ein gesundes Maß gefunden inzwischen, dass er immer noch auch jedenfalls einen Kontra gibt, aber auf eine menschliche Art und Weise. Bestimmt hat er auch immer noch irgendwie Aussagen, wo er mit Journalisten voll aneinander gerät und so. Das finde ich auch in Ordnung. Aber damals hat er so eine – da war das noch mehr getragen von einer gewissen Überheblichkeit, die vielleicht dann jetzt auch sich im Alter ein bisschen verloren hat. Aber jetzt die letzten paar Jahre habe ich auch gedacht, hat er sich vielleicht ein bisschen abgenutzt. Dafür verfolge ich aber den auch nicht täglich genug. Uli hat gerade so ein bisschen genickt, also vielleicht ist er auch immer noch so sehr pampig. Ich habe immer das Gefühl, das ist ein bisschen besser geworden. Aber das ist auf jeden Fall, was ich mit ihm sehr verbunden habe, weil wenn du dann – das mochte ich einfach nicht, die Art und Weise, ehrlicherweise. Meine Mutter fand ihn voll toll. Jürgen Klopp ist auch einer, der im Sportstudio sitzt, der weiß, welche Hebel er bewegen und welche Knöpfe er drücken muss, damit er bei einem gewissen Teil vom Publikum sehr sympathisch ankommt. Ich fand das nie außerordentlich zwischenmenschlich okay, was er gemacht hat, manchmal mit ihm gegenüberstehenden.
Es ist ausgewälter geworden, glaube ich. Er hat mehr verstanden, wie es zu nutzen hat. Nicht so selten, die Momente auf Pressekonferenzen. Ich kann jetzt nicht sagen, mir gegenüber war es immer echt in Ordnung. Ich habe sogar eher das Gefühl gehabt, wenn ich da war, die seltenen Male in England oder so, oder ich glaube, auch die Kollegen geht es genauso, dann hat er sich eher gefreut, dass deutsche Medien da sind. In dem Fall ist es ja eh ein bisschen schwierig, weil Raphael Honigstein gestern zum Beispiel da war in Liverpool. Die kennen sich ja nur mal ganz gut. Das merkt man auch, dass sie sich ganz gut kennen und dass sie sich auch, glaube ich, schätzen. Deswegen ist es da immer seltener. Aber die englischen Kollegen, ich habe ein paar, die Beatwriters in Liverpool, die finden ihn jetzt auch nicht immer so cool, weil da schon manchmal auch ausgewählt dann so ein Rant kommt, um halt von dem Thema abzulenken. Aber das zählt halt inzwischen mit dazu zur Taktik. Mit diesem Abwasser musst du wahrscheinlich gebadet sein, inzwischen, um damit klar zu kommen.
Ich habe ihn im 2009en Interview persönlich mal bekommen. Da war er mit Dortmund in Marbella im Trainingslager. Und dann hat mir damals der BVB-Presse-Sprecher Schneckis gesagt, ja, der eigentlich macht das nicht, aber der macht gerade ein Interview mit irgendeinem Radio, laufe einfach hoch und setze dich dazu und dann kannst du auch noch ein paar Fragen stellen. Und dann bin ich da in diesen Raum rein und dann hat er sich umgeräht und hat gemeint, was willst du jetzt hier? Ja, der Schneck hat gesagt, ich darf mich da zusetzen, noch ein paar Fragen stellen. Das fand er schon mal überhaupt nicht cool. Und als die Dame, die dann das Radiointerview gemacht hat, fertig war, dann habe ich mich dann zu ihm gesetzt und dann war die erste Frage so. Und dann ist er aber im Gespräch aufgelockert. Und dann haben wir uns im Schluss echt ganz gut unterhalten. Aber da habe ich so die beiden Seiten von ihm kennengelernt, so ein bisschen am Anfang erst mal so, der ist wow, fuck, lass mich ein bisschen in Ruhe, weißt du, was soll das jetzt? Und dann, wenn man über Fußball mit ihm spricht und so, und man vielleicht auch weil er gemerkt hat, dass es irgendwie eine ordentliche Diskussion ist oder eine Unterhaltung ist, ist er dann auch aufgeblüht. Und dann haben wir uns noch ganz nett unterhalten und dann war das auch echt in Ordnung. Und dann, ja, habe ich einfach in dem Moment schon festgestellt, der Mensch kann halt sehr, sehr pumpig sein und sehr böse sein, sage ich mal, an 5 Zeichen gegenüber Journalisten. Aber er kann natürlich auch, wenn er Bock hat, sehr charming sein und sehr, sehr gute Sachen erzählen. Da hat er übrigens auch erzählt am Ende des Interviews, dass er sich sehr gut vorstellen kann, nochmal in Spanien zu prämieren. Ab und zu hat er ja noch irgendwelche Ersätze daraus, wie eine Servicen-Abhör-Favor oder irgendso was. Ich kann mir vorstellen, dass er nach seinem Serbettickel oder was auch immer er macht, wenn er nicht Bundestrainer wird, vielleicht sogar nochmal in der Liga angewährt. Da muss er noch ein paar Jahre warten, bis das hier wieder erstklikereif sind, aber dann wäre es natürlich der Wahnsinn.
Ich glaube, dass Klopp den einen Vorteil hat bei seinen, sag ich jetzt mal, beiden großen Stationen, dass er jeweils die herausfordernde Rolle hatte und die war finanziell klar zu definieren. Das heißt, das Narrativ war immer, er war der Underdog. In beiden Stationen hat er es geschafft, einen Klub wo rauszuziehen. Also in Dortmund war es logischerweise ein anderes Loch als in Liverpool, aber das Loch in Liverpool war schon auch da. Jetzt will ich nicht sagen, ja, Brendan Rodgers war in der Saison, bevor er entlassen wurde, zweiter. Und die waren echt nah dran. Liebe Grüße an Steven Gerrard. Habe ich gestern noch mal gesehen, weil es Jesse gegen Liverpool war, als er da wegrutscht. Und ja, davor hat Rafa Benitez auch mal die Champions League gewonnen und zumindest hat Rafa Benitez sie wieder in die sogenannten Big Six gebracht. Über das Konstrukt muss man ja auch schon mal lauter nachdenken, dieser Tage wieder. Aber grundsätzlich war es trotzdem eine komplett andere Größenordnung des Vereins, weil Liverpool hat sich zum damaligen Zeitpunkt Rafa Benitez mit Ach und Krach für zwei Saison Fernando Torres leisten können, der als Talent kam. Heutzutage ist es Standard, dass Weltklassiker bei Liverpool im Gespräch sind, wenn sie sie wollen. Und da hat Klopp seinen Anteil dran. Ich will sagen, das, glaube ich, hilft ihm enorm, dass man die fehlenden Liga-Titel, oder dass es nur der eine war am Ende in der Amtszeit, dass man die trotzdem wegrechnet. Und zu Recht auch sagt, das ist auch tatsächlich dann am Ende meine Conclusio der ganzen Sache, zu Recht auch sagt, er steht halt neben Schenckli und Paisley in der Reihe der größten Liverpool-Manager, die es gibt, weil er diesen Verein auf das Niveau gebracht hat. Es kann dann auch der Fluch sein, an dem sie jetzt direkt anzuknüpfen haben, weil sie auf gar keinen Fall jemals wieder runterfallen wollen von dem Sockel. Aber die Parallelen hören ja da nicht auf zu Liverpool und Dortmund zueinander. Deswegen passt es ja auch so gut, glaube ich. Das sind schon ähnliche Standorte, das ist ein grundsätzliches Umfeld, es waren ähnliche Ausgangslagen und er hat sie auch in einem ähnlichen Fahrwasser dann verlassen jetzt letztlich. Auch wenn es klar ist, wie das hinten raus bei Dortmund lief, aber das hat ja im Status erstmal nichts geändert. Das, glaube ich, wird für immer da reinspielen, dass die Amtszeiten so oder so positiv bewertet werden. Vor allen Dingen ja auch, weil die europäischen Erfolge da waren und weil man da ja das Gefühl hatte, im Vergleich waren es ja eher gallische Dörfer, die da gespielt haben oder gegengepresst haben, um es richtig zu machen.
Ich glaube, was er immer geschafft hat und ziemlich schnell ist, dass er die Fans überzeugt, dass er die hinter sich bringt. Ich kann mich erinnern, dass er in der ersten Saison in Liverpool – ich habe hier ein paar englische Kumpels hin mal, und einen absoluten Liverpool-Fan – und er war schon beim Signing total begeistert. Und da lief es ja am Anfang nicht so, aber er und sein Liverpool-Umfeld, die waren alle so, nee, nee, nee, der macht das, der ist geil, der bringt uns wieder wohin. Also ich glaube, dass er relativ schnell von den Fans zumindest ein Feedback und gutes Feedback bekommen hat, egal wo er war natürlich.
Das glaube ich, was Uli gerade auch sagt, der hat das vermittelt dieses Wir-sind-wieder-wer und ich glaube, das werden sie ihm halt nie irgendwie vergessen.
Kann man das Logo draus machen, im Scouser, mehr sei mehr auf Scouser.
Ja, also die lieben ihn. Ich habe viel mit den Jungs von The Anfield Rap oder hauptsächlich sind es Jungs zu tun. Die haben auch eine Doku über Jürgen Klopp gemacht, ich glaube, vor zwei Jahren. Da hatten die mich als angefragt, ob ich ihnen erklären kann, warum Jürgen Klopp in Deutschland so gut war. Da habe ich gesagt, total nett, dass ihr fragt, aber da gibt es noch viel, viel bessere Experten. Ich sitze hier in München und so weiter und habe zwei, drei Namen genannt. Die Doku hat er dann später auch gesehen, fand sie gut und so weiter. Aber die sind total struck in love und die haben auch so ein gewisses Grundvertrauen gehabt. Also zum Beispiel, als jetzt Endo gewechselt ist im Sommer, habe ich denen noch geschrieben, Mensch, Glückwunsch, da habt ihr wirklich jemanden guten geholt. Endo, das könnte richtig was sein, was euch noch gefehlt hat im Mittelfeld. Und da waren die gleich so, ja, das versteht hier drüben keiner, wir haben auch in die Daten geguckt und er hat doch gesagt, dass der gut ist und dann muss der doch auch genau da sein. Warum haben die Leute immer noch kein Vertrauen? Also, und das ist halt auch etwas, was du erstmal schaffen musst als Trainer. Und was vielleicht auch wichtiger ist, als wir vorhin dann so darüber gesprochen haben, das Verhältnis zu den Journalistinnen und Journalisten, da habe ich mir dann auch die Frage gestellt, ja, aber ist das vielleicht wichtig? Also klar, für uns ist es wichtig, der persönlichen Zusammenarbeit. Aber wenn du jetzt nicht total unmöglich bist, ist es doch eigentlich total egal. Und eigentlich ist doch der sportliche Erfolg und das, was du mit den Spielern erstmal machst, das Allerwichtigste, oder? Und da muss man dann doch sagen, Uli, in dem Bereich ist dann vielleicht die größte Kompetenz zu sehen. Also, weil wenn du zu Underdog-Teams wächstest und mit denen erfolgreich bist, klar, dann haftet dir der unausgesprochene Vorwurf an, zeigst uns jetzt erstmal, dass du auch mit einem Top-Team immer bestehen kannst. Plus, bei Jürgen Klopp gab es ja auch oft die Diskussion, die verlorenen Finalspiele und so weiter und so fort. Bis er dann endlich mal eins gewonnen hat, möchte man ja schon fast sagen. Aber was ja schon immer da war – korrigiere mich, wenn du es anders siehst – ist, dass er Spieler weiterentwickelt hat. Und das ist ja eigentlich die Kernkompetenz.
Und auch, es gab Ewigkeiten. Also ja, es gab Warnock und so. Passt schon, da sind ein paar aus der Akademie durchgebrochen. Kelly und wie sie alle hießen, die halt dann nach drei Jahren weitergegangen sind und dann bei Wigan Athletic ihre Karriere beendet haben oder irgendwie so. Ich will denen gar nicht zu nahe treten, alles gut. Aber Trent Alexander-Arnold, jetzt gerade, Curtis Jones, die sind absolute Leistungsträger geworden. Alexander-Arnold noch mehr als Curtis Jones, aber Queen Kelly aus Nummer 2, aufgebaut von Klopp, den ich für eine der besten zweiten Torhüter überhaupt halte in der Premier League. Passt perfekt. Connor Bradley, gestern jetzt getroffen, wieder eine Vorlage gemacht, den haben wir gar nicht auf dem Schirm gehabt. Der hat letztes Jahr die dritte Liga gespielt und plötzlich ist er auf dem Niveau und es sieht so aus, klar, kein Ding, könnten wir so machen, kein Problem. Dann Quonsa, gerade in der Innenverteidigung wieder. Das sind jetzt nur die aktuellen Beispiele, die mir einfallen. HW Elliott weiterentwickelt, wirklich von einem 16-Jährigen, von dem ich manchmal dachte, geiler Zocker, aber das war es dann auch schon, hin zu einem seriösen Mittelfeldspieler, der definitiv noch was machen wird. Und, und, und, also zig Beispiele von Spielern, die er aufs nächste Niveau gehoben hat oder komplett von einem anderen Niveau hochgebracht hat und das Ganze aber immer mit einem – also es ist jetzt nicht so, dass man da Löcher hatte in dem Kader, sondern immer mit einer Weitsicht und Auge eingebaut schon, weil sie einfach besser waren. Und trotzdem ja einen riesengroßen Kader. Also inzwischen die Offensive, das ist das Beste, was Europa zu bieten hat, auch an verschiedenen Profilen. Da ist kein Underdog. Also das kann man alles schön vergessen. Luiz Dias, David Núñez, Mohamed Salah, Diogo Jota und Cody Gagbo. Ja, danke. Also das ist schon sehr gut, deswegen ja, volle Zustimmung zu dem. Das hat er immer getan, zu jedem Zeitpunkt mit genau dem richtigen Auge, glaube ich auch und auch. Ich hatte mal so eine Zeit lang die Angst, dass sie sich ein bisschen zu sehr verlieben in die Fab 3 da vorne mit Firmino, mit Salah, mit Mané. Aber gerade am Beispiel Sadio Mané, und das habe ich hier auch mal gesagt, deswegen, ich bin on the record damit, dass ich vor dem Bayernwechsel gesagt habe, Vorsicht, Vorsicht. Es hat absolute Gründe, warum die den gehen lassen, weil die gemerkt haben, der macht jetzt den dritten oder vierten Putsch versucht, der zu inszenieren, weil er die Nummer 1 sein will da vorne drin und denkt, dass er viel besser ist als Mohamed Salah. Und Klopp hat zu jedem Zeitpunkt verstanden, nee, ist er nicht. Weder sportlich noch menschlich ist er besser. Also haben sie ihn schön rauskomplimentiert für einiges an Geld für den damals 30-Jährigen. Und Firmino haben sie dann in der Folgesaison, da hat er dann nochmal sehr gut, der hat eine sehr gute Phase nochmal gehabt und auch dann haben sie den ebenfalls gehen lassen. Bei Fabinho war es das gleiche als Beispiel, der mir unheimlich gut gefallen hat und dann haben sie gesehen, oh, zweites Formloch von dem, lieber trennen. Das heißt, auch da haben sie echt ganze Arbeit geleistet, sie haben eben nicht an der Nostalgie festgehalten, sondern haben verstanden, nee, wir müssen jetzt umbauen und müssen, man sagt ja jetzt in England Liverpool 2.0 gerade, sie müssen jetzt übergehen in Liverpool 2.0 und das ist erstaunlich und darüber hinaus auch noch, also das knüpft ja an das an, was ihr gerade gesagt habt. Also bei ENDO haben sich einige verwundert die Augen gerieben, aber als der Name Schmatke kam, haben mir einige Kollegen aus England geschrieben und haben mich gefragt, wer soll denn Jörg Schmatke sein, der hat halt gearbeitet in Wolfsburg, wollte ja uns verarschen, aber wenn Jürgen Klopp bürgt für ihn persönlich und das hat er ja getan, weil die beiden gut miteinander sind, dann passt es. Dann haben selbst bei Liverpool alle gesagt, dann wird es schon stimmen. Und das ist echt, das muss man ja sagen, das spricht wieder dafür, er hat den Verein voll im Griff, kann halt aber auch sein, dass sie merken, oh Mist, der hat den Verein voll im Griff und jetzt ist er aber nicht mehr da.
Letztes Thema noch, also Jürgen Klopp hat gesagt in seiner Pressekonferenz, erst gab es das Video, wo er gesagt hat, ich habe keine Energie mehr und deswegen das war quasi sein Statement an die Liverpool-Familien, nenne ich es jetzt einfach mal, und dann gab es die Pressekonferenz und hat er gesagt, ich kann euch eins versprechen, ich werde jetzt mindestens ein Jahr Pause machen, ich werde nie wieder in England einen anderen Club trainieren und im nächsten Jahr werde ich kein Nationalteam und keinen Verein übernehmen. Uli, wie hätte Jürgen Klopp das kommunizieren sollen? Hätte er es noch irgendwo hin tapezieren sollen? Damit nicht die Diskussion losgeht, wird er im Sommer Nationaltrainer. Ich meine, klar, die liegen am Boden. Also größeren Underdog gab es schon lange nicht mehr. Ich verstehe es. Aber das ist doch eigentlich total absurd.
Ja, das wundert mich schon auch immer. Und jetzt würde er gefragt, würden sie nicht doch weiter machen, weil sie haben ja jetzt gewonnen gegen Chelsea. Ja, okay, da ist die Energie wieder da. Ja, kein Ding. Ich finde es auch immer wieder erstaunlich, dass wenn jemand sich so klar äußert. Und ich meine, jetzt wird ja schon bekannt gegeben. Ich habe jetzt nur gelesen. Irgendwie reicht mir dann auch wirklich in der Überschrift, welches tolles Haus er sich in Wiesbaden jetzt gekauft hat und so. Da kann er dann mit Breda Redi schönstarken wahrscheinlich. Ist mir alles wurscht. Also wenn er mir sagt und das glaube ich ihm, ich möchte gerade nicht mehr arbeiten, dann glaube ich ihm das. Und warum die Medien ihm das nicht glauben, ist mir egal. Weiß ich nicht. Aber wahrscheinlich ist die Antwort wie immer Klicks.
Ja, ich meine, die die Geschichten sind natürlich auch schön. Also ich verstehe dann auch die die Fans, die dann sagen. Okay, also folgendes Tuchel bei Bayern weg Klopp zu Tuchel Tuchel zu Barca und so weiter. Und dann das ist halt ja einfach Fußball Manager 2000, was man da dann durchspielt.
Aber keiner braucht bei zwei Wochen Zeit für den Umzug oder so, sondern im Sommer wird Barcelona frei. Also dann geht Tuchel dahin. Dann wird ja Bayern frei. Dann geht Xabi Alonso zu Bayern. Ach Mist, Liverpool ist frei. Dann lieber nach Liverpool. Und jetzt braucht Bayern.
Wir müssen Hansi Flick noch irgendwo unterbekommen.
Also ja, angeblich gab es ja Gespräche von Barca mit ihm nach dem Sextuppel. Das wurde jetzt wieder aufgewärmt. Aber gibt es denn die DFB-Drucke auch in der spanischen Synchronisation? Weiß das jemand von euch?
Ich habe sie hier entdeckt in der Mediathek, aber ich glaube nur auf Englisch übersetzt und Deutsch natürlich. Aber Laporta ist angeblich ein großer Fan von ihm.
Was heißt denn Klopp ganz auf Spanisch?
Man muss mal aufpassen, ob der überhaupt noch Präsident ist oder wie lange der noch Präsident ist.
Fährt einfach eine Social Media Kampagne, dann läuft das schon. Über Klopp wird es eine Doku geben übrigens zu dieser letzten Saison jetzt. Es ist noch nicht klar, wer die ausstrahlen wird und wahrscheinlich dreht sie Liverpool selbst, was dann eher unterwältigend sein dürfte. Aber ein paar interessante Dinge erhoffe ich mir dann trotzdem davon. Also wenigstens so 10 Prozent oder so.
Aber ansonsten muss ich mich da gerade mit dem von Uli Gesagten anschließen. Ich bin auch eher Fan davon. Ich sehe, er sagt das. Und dann habe ich aber auch das Glück, dass ich nicht zu der Journalistengruppe zähle, der jetzt damit halt auch Geld verdient, dass ich jeden Tag einen neuen Artikel darüber schreibe. Also das muss man auch sagen. Ich kann mich privilegiert zurücklehnen und sagen, mache ich bei Transfers auch so. Heute Abend von Marius lasse ich mir alles, was fix ist, erzählen und an den ganzen True-or-Not-True-Sachen zwischendrin beteilige ich mich nicht.
Warum trägt ihr eigentlich kein Gelb? Haben wir heute nicht Deadline-Day?
Leute. Ich bin später noch da. Also wer will? Ich werde auch kein Gelb tragen, das hätte ich aber gladelos vergessen.
Ja, auf die Doku kann man dann, glaube ich, gespannt sein. Ich meine, wenn die Inhalte gut sind, kann die Doku noch so schlecht gemacht sein und sie ist trotzdem irgendwie sehenswert. Born for. This ist dafür das perfekte Beispiel. Völlig überproduziert. Keine Sekunde, in dem man nicht durch die Musik gesagt wird, wie man jetzt gerade zu empfinden hat. Aber die Darstellerin, also die Frauen-Nationalspielerin, die sagen so interessante Sachen. Die sagen auch Sachen, die im Männerkosmos wirklich Schlagzeilen zerborsten hätten. Das ist quasi, dass man sich trotzdem angucken kann, obwohl es so fürchterlich überproduziert ist. Also das lässt hoffen für diese Jürgen Klopp-Doku. Und vielleicht kann ich es jetzt verraten. Jürgen Klopp sollte immer 11 Lebensstaffel 2 sein. Das war eigentlich damals mein Plan. Ich wollte Jürgen Klopp eine Saison begleiten und wollte dann anhand seiner Person nicht nur erzählen seine persönliche Geschichte, sondern wie Trainer eigentlich arbeiten, weil ich glaube, das ist immer noch ein unterbelichteter Bereich im Fußball, obwohl es schon die Trainer-Doku mal gab von Aljosha Pause und so weiter und so fort. Aber – und es gab sogar Gespräche, aber ihr werdet es auch schon alle kennengelernt haben, an Jürgen Klopp heranzukommen. Das war einem gewissen Punkt nicht mehr möglich. Deswegen leider nie was draus. Sagen wir es so, über einen Werbedeal hätte es geklappt. Aber dann wäre es nicht mehr mein Projekt gewesen. Und deswegen habe ich dann gesagt, nee. Also dann doch nicht. Aber gut, das führt jetzt zu weiter. Ich weiß jetzt auch gar nicht, wie weit ich noch erzählen darf. Ist er nur im Rasenfunk. Macht keine Snippets draus und schickt es weiter. Also Jürgen Klopp, er wird uns irgendwann noch weiter beschäftigen. Aber wir haben schon noch ein paar andere Themen. Und jetzt ist es ein bisschen kürzer, die anderen liegen. Verzeiht es uns, liebe Hörerinnen und Hörer. Allerdings kamen auch so viele Nachfragen nach. Macht ihr noch was zu Klopp im Rasenfunk? Deswegen hoffe ich, dass es jetzt dann trotzdem passt. Fabian, ich würde sagen, wir machen bei dir weiter. Weil da ist ja jetzt der nächste Job von Jürgen Klopp frei geworden. Ist mir doch ganz egal, was der gesagt hat. Er wird jetzt Nachfolger von Xavi. Denn der hat endgültig Adios gesagt.
Ja, der hat Adios gesagt. Aber ich würde es ihm nicht empfehlen. Ich glaube, er ist auch klug genug, diesen Job jetzt erstmal nicht anzunehmen. Es ist tatsächlich so, wie Xavi das gesagt hat. Es ist ein absoluter, ja, brennender Stuhl, auf dem man sich selbst bei Barcelona setzt. Ein Verein, der hochverschuldet ist, der medial viele Probleme hat, der einen Präsidenten hat, der sehr zwielichtige Geschäfte macht, der in einem schiedsichtigen Skandal verwickelt ist und bei dem man trotzdem erwartet, dass er ständig erst oder zweiter ist und in der Champions League mindestens ins Finale kommt und so weiter. Und dementsprechend ist es, glaube ich, im Moment überhaupt kein dankbarer Trainerjob. Und bei Xavi muss man das vielleicht noch mal auf mehreren Ebenen sehen. Der war ja nicht der fahrendste Trainer. Er hatte eine Station vorher in Saudi-Arabien und dann gleich zu Barca. Da ist er natürlich dann die Legende und hat einen ganz anderen Status gehabt als Trainer vor ihm, die schneller gehen mussten, die weniger erfolgreich waren wie er, aber schneller gehen mussten. Ich glaube, Alex hat das letzte Mal beim letzten Ligatour schon angesprochen. Ernesto Valverde und so weiter und so fort. Die mussten alle gehen, obwohl sie sportlich top dastanden, aber dann hat es halt im Media nicht gepasst. Bei Xavi war halt einfach der Legendenstatus da und deswegen hat man ihm vieles verziehen und verteidigt ihm nach wie vor vieles. Er hat jetzt mit dieser Pressekonferenz eine Kerbe geschlagen, einen Knick reinbekommen in seiner Darstellung, in seiner medialen Darstellung, aber auch in der Darstellung gegenüber den Fans, die ihm jetzt, glaube ich, noch mal positiv gepusht hat und pushen wird in den nächsten Wochen. Weil es wirklich, glaube ich, sehr, sehr schwer im Moment ist, dort zu trainieren. Ich glaube, die Mannschaft ist nicht gut zusammengestellt. Es sind viele Charaktere in der Mannschaft, die es schwer machen, ein gutes Teambuilding hinzubekommen. Ein Lewandowski zum Beispiel, der schon ein bisschen drüber ist, der sich mit Jungspielern an Talenten angelegt hat. Ja, da stimmt vieles nicht, im Mittelfeld nicht. Und deswegen ist es ziemlich schwierig, ihn jetzt wirklich da so zu bewerten. Ich fand seine sportliche Entwicklung sowieso viel zufriedener. Du kannst nicht nach Saudi-Arabien direkt zu Barca gehen. Das ist, was Uli vorher gesagt hat. Wenn du als Xavi Alonso von der 2. Mannschaft von San Sebastian zu Leverkusen gehst, Bundesliga, dort in Ruhe arbeiten kannst, dann kannst du dir langsam eine Karriere aufbauen. Bei Xavi war der Schritt einfach von 0 auf 100 viel zu groß. Und da geht auch kein Legendenstatus drüber. Und dementsprechend fand ich sehr sympathisch, was er gesagt hat und sehr ehrlich. Er wurde, wie gesagt, im Media schon seit Wochen, Monaten an den Pranger gestellt. Alle seine Aussagen, weil er sich immer wieder entschuldigt hat. Oh, der Rasen war schlecht. Oh, das Licht war zu grill. Oh, weiß ich nicht was. Irgendwas ist ihm immer eingefallen. Aber er hat immer seine Mannschaft verteidigt, was man ihm zugutehalten muss. Und sie haben ihm wirklich das Leben nicht leicht gemacht. Vor allen Dingen die Medien hier in Spanien. Und jetzt zieht er einen Schlussstrich. Und ich glaube, wie gesagt, dass ihm das jetzt noch mal positiv pushen wird, auf die Mannschaft noch mal positiv pushen wird, für die letzten Monate jetzt.
Aber das heißt, das, was er da gesagt hat auf der Pressekonferenz, war eben das, was du anfangs gesagt hast, dass es eben ein brennender Stuhl ist, auf dem man sich setzt und wo überall die Probleme liegen. Also legt man ihm quasi positiv aus, dass er da so offen jetzt endlich mal drüber geredet hat?
Genau, genau. Also ich meine, man hat es ja gesehen. Man sieht es jede Woche hier, wie nervig es sein muss, im Moment Barcelona-Trainer zu sein, wie man ständig hier in Spanien auch schnell von der Presse eine Scheldung bekommt. Und da hat mit Sicherheit nicht von Vorteil gewirkt, dass er eben als Trainer noch nicht so viel Erfahrung hatte. Dann konnte man halt noch leichter auf ihn draufhauen, sage ich jetzt mal. Und genau, und dementsprechend, ja, war das eine ganz schwierige Situation für ihn, weil es ja eigentlich sein Lieblingsverein ist, weil es seine Heimat ist, weil er ja gerne das macht, weil er es ja liebt, weil er dort wohnt, weil das sein alles ist. Aber trotzdem haben sie ihn jetzt in eineinhalb Jahren quasi so weit bekommen, dass er sagt, ne Jungs, bei aller Liebe, das kann ich nicht mehr machen. Und deswegen, ocho, aufgepasst, wer über diesen Trainerstuhl übernimmt im Sommer, es ist nicht ein easy Job.
Aber wirst du, wenn das zulässig ist überhaupt, Xavi jetzt mal von Barcelona zu trennen, das ist die Frage, die ich mir noch stelle, wie geht denn deine Einordnung des Trainers, Xavi? Ich habe die ein paar Mal gemacht, jetzt über die Jahre auch, und der Saison zwei oder drei Mal. Und ich weiß überhaupt nicht, was ich mit dem anfangen soll. Also ist er jetzt als Trainer gut oder schlecht? Oder ist er in Progress sozusagen? Siehst du was, wie würdest du den einordnen? Das ist die für mich so spannende Frage. Ich weiß gar nicht, was ich mit ihm machen soll.
Das ist genau mein Punkt eigentlich, weil ich ihn eigentlich schon auch von Anfang an mitkritisiert habe. Natürlich nicht so Schelten-mäßig wie die spanische Presse drauf gehabt. Aber ich habe mir immer gesagt, der ist jetzt hier Trainer, weil er halt Xavi ist, aber nicht, weil er tolle Ideen hat, weil er Spielsysteme umsetzen kann, weil er gut mit den Leuten umgehen kann, weil er eine krasse Erfahrung hat. No way! Also da war, weiß ich nicht, für mich hat es nie so wirklich gepasst. Ich habe ihn auch nie gegriffen, habe nie gewusst, was sein Ziel ist und so weiter. Er hat so viel umgestellt und personell und systemmäßig. Und da war für mich keine gerade Linie zu sehen. Und dementsprechend weiß ich auch nicht, ob der, wenn er noch jetzt eine andere Trainerstation bekommt, ob das jetzt erstmal wieder ein großer Klub ist, das wage ich mal zu bezweifeln. Da würde sich jetzt erstmal keiner antrauen, weil ich sehe es nicht im Moment, dass er da irgendwie einen Verein weiter drinnen kann. Vielleicht muss er es tatsächlich nochmal eine Stufe drunter probieren, oder zwei, und kann sich dort nochmal messen, weil Erfahrung als Spieler hat er natürlich, und natürlich hat er auch viele Trainer erlebt, und der Juwari Diola hat da mit Sicherheit einiges gelernt, die stehen auch im Regen-Austausch, aber am Ende steht halt er in der Kabine, gibt er die Sachen vor, muss er mit den Spielern sprechen, muss er die Taktik vorgeben, und für mich ist das nicht Top-Class.
Aber wie hast du das gerade gemeint mit dem medialen Push, den er sich jetzt damit geholt hat, im Sinne von der Mannschaft, dass er dir seine Ehre gepackt hat? Oder ich habe das gerade nicht ganz verstanden, wie du das gemeint hast, ehrlicherweise?
Na ja, zum einen kriegst du die Medienschälte jetzt erstmal nicht mehr so krass die nächsten Wochen, weil du jetzt dir erstmal gesagt hast, okay, ihr drescht mir auf mich ein, deswegen höre ich auf, dann werden die jetzt mit Sicherheit ein bisschen leichter mit ihm umgehen. Und auch die Spieler werden jetzt so – Mitleid ist ein blödes Wort, aber die haben natürlich auch mitbekommen, hey, da ist einer, der hat sich aufgeopfert für uns, der wollte alles für den Verein, alles für den Klub, der steht jeden Tag am Training da und will was von uns. Und wir haben es halt einfach nicht gut gemacht. Und ich denke, dass wir ihm jetzt auch deswegen vielleicht noch einen guten Abschied zubereiten wollen und nochmal alles reinwerfen werden in den nächsten Wochen.
Da gehe ich schon von aus.
Also ausnahmsweise für den Trainer spielen dann?
Ausnahmsweise und mal für den Trainer, genau.
Weil schon die Frage ist, was überhaupt noch drin ist. Also Barca rank 4, 7 Punkte hinter Real, 8 hinter Girona. Real hat noch ein Spiel weniger. Also kann Barca darüber hinaus noch irgendwas erreichen? Ach so ja, Champions League. Was war das? Neapel?
Habe ich jetzt richtig gemerkt? Das ist tatsächlich irgendwie das Aufeinandertreffen der zwei kaputtesten Klubs innerhalb kürzester Zeit.
Na gut, dann schauen wir, wie es bei Barca weitergeht. Und dann blicken wir aber auch einmal nochmal auf die Serie. A, denn da steht ein ganz besonderes Spiel an. Und es wäre sowieso schon besonders, wenn ich aber jetzt die Tabellenkonstellation nenne, dann wird es nochmal eindeutig. Inter hat 54 Punkte, allerdings ein Spiel weniger als Verfolger Juve. Und Juve hat in Unterzahl gegen Empoli nur 1 zu 1 gespielt. Deswegen aktuell ein Punkt Rückstand auf Inter. Es könnten mit dem Nachholspiel von Inter, bzw. es ist kein Nachholspiel, wenn Inter dann spielt, könnten es dann 4 Punkte sein. Und jetzt treffen Mario die beiden Teams am Sonntag aufeinander. Und das ist ja ein Must-Watch-Match.
Ja, absolut. Da habe ich gedacht, ich bringe mal diese Woche den Captain Obvious mit. Aber da fiebern natürlich alle auch in Italien drauf hin. Und ich schon auch. Das steht so viel auf dem Spiel. Also Juve, wir haben gerade vorhin von Liverpool 2.0 gesprochen. Ist eigentlich auch Juve 2.0, aber eigentlich ist es Juve 1.0. Also zurück zur alten Stärke. Und die Stärke ist halt dann 1-0 gewinnen.
Aber wurde das jetzt nicht ein bisschen besser? Das hat Christian vor zwei Wochen erzählt, dass man so hoffen kann, dass es jetzt ein bisschen…
Christian ist auch immer so ein Allegri-Versteher. Und der nimmt die dann immer an den Schutz. Also es wurde teilweise besser und natürlich hast du mit einem… Wenn du den Kenan Yildiz-Spielen siehst, da ist dann Tempo und Spielwitz und so vorhanden. Aber es kommt dann von einzelnen Spielern. Aber es ist schon tatsächlich unabhängig von den Einzelaktionen teils ein statisches Spiel. Es ist besser geworden. Sie haben eine super stabile Abwehr. Und ja, dann gibt ihnen der Erfolg Recht. Und wenn wir uns jetzt das Spiel angucken, ist es einfach Tatsache, dass auch wenn sie dann ein Spiel mehr haben, dann könnte Juve mit einem Sieg an die Tabellenspitze rücken. Und dann, glaube ich, damit hätten vor allem, wenn man den Namen Juve sagt vor der Saison, die wenigsten gerechnet. Klar, dass es irgendwie ein Zwei-Kampf-Drei-Kampf wird. Ja, vielleicht schon. Aber da hatten vielleicht noch einige eher Milan in der Verlosung oder doch nochmal Napoli. Haben wir ja gerade schon gehört. Also bei Napoli geht gerade gar nichts zusammen. Und ich finde es deswegen auch so ein spannendes Duell, natürlich historisch gesehen. Ich glaube, es ist das 238. Aufeinandertreffen in Pflichtspielen zwischen den beiden. Allein in San Siro haben sie sich schon 119 Mal duelliert. Also das bringt viel Historie mit sich. Man hat Bilder, Trikots von einzelnen Spielern vor Augen. Man hat auch jetzt so Personal das hervorsticht. Also auch da gerne mache ich den Captain Obvious. Es ist halt auch das Duell Lautaro-Martinez gegen Dujan Flavic. Bei Argentinien 28 Pflichtspiele, 22 Treffer, nur drei per Strafstoß, muss man auch mal sagen. Und auch Liga bereinigt sogar 19 Spiele, 19 Tore, zwei per Strafstoß. Lautaro-Martinez läuft heiß. Der hat Ende Dezember mal zwei Partien gefehlt. Da haben sie dann auch direkt mal Punkte gelassen beim Aufsteiger Genoa. Und das war eines von drei Remis. Bei Juve kommt nur eine Saisonniederlage. Beide lustigerweise gegen Sassu Olo. Abstiegskandidat diese Saison. Das sind die einzigen zwei Niederlagen. Oder jeweils die eine Niederlage. Und Lautaro finde ich deswegen so bemerkenswert. Der hatte dann eben eine Zwei-Spiele-Pause wegen einer Adduktoren-Verletzung und kam zurück. Und vier Tore in drei Liga-Spielen. Tor und Vorlage jetzt bei diesem komischen Super-Kopper-Konstrukt bei den Scheichs. Wo es Inter tatsächlich auch – die Spieler haben sich super drüber gefreut. Das gehört ja auch immer dazu. Und ich sage ja zumindest jetzt wieder schon mal ein Pokal in die Vitrine geholt. Aber wo wir gerade bei dem sind, für den wäre schon diese Meisterschaft mit Inter. Und deswegen ist auch das Spiel so wichtig. Schon der nächste Meilenstein, weil Skudetto hat er noch nicht geholt. Und er hat zweimal mit Inter, nachdem er von Konte übernommen hat, gerade so in der Phase Frühlingsbeginn, sich oft, weil er davor nicht rotiert hat, auf einmal so selber ein Bein gestellt und Inter ist eingebrochen. Und es gab auch jetzt in den letzten Wochen, gerade in der Phase, wo dann Lautaro nicht da war, habe ich auch mal kurz so skeptisch geguckt. Was machen sie jetzt? Hat im Tage wieder nicht das richtige Maß an Rotation einfließen lassen. Deswegen steht für beide Teams, aber glaube ich auch für Inter, ein bisschen mehr auf dem Spiel. Weil Juve hat sich die letzten Wochen immer als Verfolger irgendwie stilisiert. Gerade der Trainer hat viele halbphilosophischen Sachen gesagt, wie wir sind der Hase. Und dann hat er von Räuber und Schandarmspiel gesprochen. Er hat selber noch nie wirklich über die Meisterschaft gesprochen. Das ist bei den Spielern anders. Ich finde, das muss auch so sein. Da muss das Selbstverständnis da sein. Als Juve-Spieler, wenn du Zweiter bist, dann auch zu sagen, wollen wir Meister werden. Und da dann vielleicht zwei Takte zu Dusan Flavic. Der hat 22 Pflichtspiele, 12 Tore. Das ist nicht ganz so bemerkenswert wie bei Lautaro. Auf die Liga bereinigt 20 Spiele und 12 Tore. Eins per Strafstoß. Aber er läuft halt jetzt gerade richtig heiß. Der hat einen sehr guten Saisonstart gehabt, mit vier Toren an den ersten vier Spieltagen. Dann gab es einen kleinen Durchhänger. Zwischenzeitlich auch mal Rückenprobleme. Da hat er dann zwei Spiele verpasst. Und schon auf einmal kam sofort wieder diese Kritik, die Skepsis, die alle an ihm haben. Man hat ihn halt aus Florenz geholt. Man hat viele Hoffnungen gesetzt. Und dann, ah, guck mal, er funktioniert schon wieder nicht. Dann hat Aleki ein, zwei Sachen gesagt, die ihm, glaube ich, auch keinen Selbstvertrauen gegeben haben. Muss man ja auch sagen, der ist immer noch super jung. Und dann hat er sechs Ligaspiele nicht getroffen. Dann endlich wieder genetzt. Das war im Hinspiel übrigens, als er 1-0 die Führung gemacht hat für Juve gegen Inter, ging dann 1-1 aus. Wer für Inter getroffen hat, könnte da überdenken vielleicht. Das war natürlich Lautaro Martinez. Und seit Ende Dezember läuft Flau, das ist so richtig heiß, das ist irgendwas von ihm abgefallen. Also in den letzten sechs Serie A-Partien immer mindestens an einem Tor beteiligt. Ende des Jahres bei so einem wichtigen 1-0 zu Hause gegen Rom, eine tolle Hakenvorarbeit für Rabiot. Sechs Tor allein im Januar in vier Spielen. Hat nur ein gewisser Cristiano Ronaldo mal geschafft, sieben Mal in einem Monat für Juve zu treffen. Und ja, also freue ich mich drauf. Ich glaube, es wird kein Offensivspektakel, weil zu viel auf dem Spiel steht. Ich glaube, beide können sehr gut mit dem Punkt leben. Aber es wird schon spannend sein, wie beide Trainer da versuchen, sich gegenseitig zu neutralisieren. Und bei Juve muss man dazu sagen, dass der große Unterschied sind, dass sind die Unentschieden. Sie haben halt schon fünf Mal Unentschieden gespielt. Jetzt zuletzt, du hast es angesprochen, gegen Empoli. Ja, haben sie ab der 18. Minute in Unterzahl gespielt und dann auch geführt. Und das ist das, glaube ich, was ich dann irgendwie, im Gegensatz zu Christian bei Juve eher kritisiere, sind sie Empolis-Vorletzter. Du kannst dich auch mit zehn Mann dominieren oder darfst zumindest nicht so passiv werden und dich hinten reinstellen. Und dann haben sie da dann verdientermaßen, ehrlicherweise noch den Ausgleich gefangen, weil sie selber ja ein bisschen zu mutlos waren. Und das ist das, was ich Allegri vorwerfe, wo Christian zu Recht oft sagt, ja gut, er hat 10 mal 1.0 gewonnen.
Ich sehe schon, irgendwann muss es da mal den Stand-off zwischen euch beiden geben. Das wird dann das nächste. Irgendwie wirkt auch Uli dreimal so, als ob er was sagen wollen würde.
Ich sage auch, ich bin einmal durchgepredert.
Na gut, wir werden es uns einfach weiter verfolgen. Und dann machen wir doch einfach der Sieger dieses Spiels. Der ist dann auch der Sieger des Dues zwischen dir und Christian. Allegri Versteher, ja oder nein, das ist dann die Frage. Und so entscheiden wir das dann. Dann lasst uns noch ganz schnell zu unseren Awards kommen. Also MVP, Unsung Hero und Moment des Spieltags. Da habt ihr alle was mitgebracht. Uli, wer wäre denn dein MVP? Oder müssen wir da jetzt, wollen wir da jetzt Jürgen Klopp eintragen? Oder hast du noch was anderes?
Ja, ich weiß ja, ich komme ohne die tägliche Dosis Luten nicht aus in dieser Ligatur. Und an einem Spieltag, in dem Lutentown, Brightonhof, Albion mit 4-0 schlägt, finde ich, dass Rob Edwards den Award verdient hat. Das ist dann der Jürgen Klopp MVP Award, den dann Rob Edwards verdient. Ich glaube, dann können alle damit leben. Also sowas habe ich noch nicht gesehen. Kenny, also wer diese Szenen noch irgendwo abgreifen kann. Das war das beste Stückchen Fußball, das wahrscheinlich da je gespielt worden ist. Das ist natürlich der Klassiker, dass der Zerbi einfach so stur da reinläuft in die tiefe Verteidigung und die machen einfach genau das. Aber so musst du es erstmal vorbereiten als gegnerischer Trainer mit den Mitteln. Luthen hat echt eine Chance drin zu bleiben. Ich glaube mehr und mehr daran. Deswegen hat sich Rob Edwards diesen Award mehr als nur verdient.
Stimmt. Das waren nämlich 1 zu 0 erste Minute, 2 zu 0 dritte Minute. Das ist genau meines Wissens nach zweimal passiert an diesem Wochenende. Einmal bei diesem Spiel und dann bei Duisburg gegen Nürnberg in der Frauen-Bundesliga. Und auch da könnte der Klub dadurch drin bleiben, ist nämlich über die Abstiegsplätze hinausgesprungen.
Hetrick Adebayo ist auch wie so ein Einhorn. Der ist so lang, der ist so dürr, so richtig drahtig. Und trotzdem kann der Ballcarrier sein. Und komischerweise gibt es so viele große Spieler, die gar nicht so richtig gut Kopfball spielen können. Das ist so ein ganz aufregender Spieler. Wenn man den sieht, merkt man immer sofort, da ist was los. Nur 60 Minuten lang, weil dann ist er meistens platt. Aber echt ein aufregender Spieler. Ich sehe den sehr gerne.
Sehr gut. Adebayo werden wir uns angucken und looten. Jetzt damit eben auch aus den Abstiegsringen herausgesprungen. Aktuell 17. mit 19 Punkten. Und überhaupt sehr, sehr gute Serie. Jetzt 3 Siege, ein Unentschieden aus den letzten 5 Spielen. Da kommen 13 der 19 Punkte her. Das ist schon einigermaßen bemerkenswert. Und dann stelle ich fest, Fabian, in der La Liga wird der MVP-Award offenbar jetzt so ein Atletico-Ding, weil wir hatten das letzte Mal Antoine Griezmann. Und jetzt freust du dich mit stolzgeschwellter und freude-strahlender Brust. Eine Brust kann jetzt auf Freude strahlen, Jürgen Klopp zu nennen.
Ja, aber das ist tatsächlich so. Ich muss ihn nennen, auch wenn ihr vielleicht aus der Vergangenheit wisst, dass ich nicht sein größter Fan bin. Aber man muss ihm zugute halten, was er gerade aus Atletico Madrid macht. Ja, hört sich gerade oder schaut gerade richtig gut aus. Ich glaube, der Pokalsieg gegen Real Madrid hat die Mannschaft doch mal richtig gepusht. Wir sind im Moment Tabellen-Dritter, haben die letzten Spiele, weiß ich nicht, drei, vier Spiele gewonnen, sind in richtig guter Form. Hat ein paar gute Spieler integriert in das Team, wie zum Beispiel in Neuzugang Samuel Lino, der im Moment ganz gut funktioniert. Sogar zwei Nachwuchsspieler sind im Moment öfter in der Stadt, mit Riquelme und Pablo Varios, die ganz viel Spaß machen. Und vorne hat man halt mit Griezmann, mit Morata, mit Memphis Depay und Angel Correa auch ein ordentliches Pfund. Und im Moment muss ich ihm einfach diesen MVP geben, kann ich nichts machen.
Das aber zeichnet dich ja aus, dass es wahre Größe ist, dass du da über deinen Schatten springst. Stellt sich die Frage, was Mario bei seinem MVP machen musste. Musstest du da auch irgendwo hinspringen?
Nein, überhaupt nicht, überhaupt nicht. Meiner heißt Matteo Retegui, spielt beim Aufsteiger aus Genoa, die tatsächlich sehr viel Spaß machen. Also da mal ein kleiner Tipp, Alberto Ciladino, der ist auch was für ein M-Faktor, aber guter Trainer tatsächlich. Die spielen schön Fußball, die werden nichts mit dem Abstieg zu tun haben. Auch eben aufgrund sehr spannenden Jungstürmers, wird auch in der italienischen Nationalmannschaft sicherlich noch auf sich aufmerksam machen. Kam aus Argentinien, die Großeltern sind italienische Stadtbürger. Papa hat unter anderem für die argentinische Feldhockey-Nationalmannschaft gespielt und die Schwester auch im Feldhockey Olympische Silber geholt. Er zockt aber ganz gut Fußball, Torschützenkönig geworden mit Tigre in der Saison 21-22. Und dann ist er eben zu Genoa für 12 Millionen. Und der hat an den ersten sieben Spieltagen direkt nach dem Aufstieg, denen schon viele Punkte gebracht, drei Tore erzielt. Und dann hat er Knieprobleme gehabt und Genoa hatte auch eine richtige Durststrecke. Jetzt ist er endlich wieder zurück. Genoa seit sieben Spielen ungeschlagen, 13 Punkte geholt. Die letzten drei davon konnte er jetzt auch endlich wieder über 90 Minuten machen. Und zwei davon davor hat Genoa immer nur Remy gespielt und jetzt haben sie zweimal in Folge gewonnen. Eben auch dank Treffer von ihm. Am letzten Wochenende hat er 0-1 zu Hause gegen Lecce mit einem Tor und einer Vorlage gedreht. Und das ist so ein Unterschiedsspieler bei einem Team, das sich jetzt einpendelt zwischen als Aufsteiger, wo du in Italien eigentlich immer Abstiegskandidat Platz 20 bist, werden die sich einpendeln auf Platz 9, 10. Sogar mit Schlagdistanz theoretisch auf, wenn es einen OE-Cup geben würde, die Richtung. Aber ich finde, das ist ganz bemerkenswert und der macht richtig Spaß. Also guck den gerne mal an.
Stark. Sehr gut. Ach, ich liebe diese Kategorie. Uli, wer ist dein Unsung-Hero?
Also normalerweise müsste ich jetzt hier looten kommen, aber die sind inzwischen so besogen. Genau, der ist total ansagen. Gibt sowas wie Oversung. Kann man jemanden zu viel besingen? Dann würde ich die Kategorie an Jürgen Klopp geben. Ich nehme mal einen, der fast schon verrissen wird, vor allen Dingen hier in Deutschland. Kai Havertz. Das nervt mich langsam. Mir ist klar, das ist kein Dog. Mit dem würde ich jetzt auch nicht zwingend in die Schlacht ziehen und sagen, wenn ich in der 90. Minute noch einen Ballbesitz habe, dann mache ich alles über Kai Havertz. Das will ich damit nicht sagen. Aber alle tun so, als wäre das ein totaler Flop und so weiter. Insbesondere, wenn man sich mal das Saka-Tor jetzt anschaut vom Nothing-in-the-Forest-Spiel bei Arsenal, dann sieht man einfach nur, dass Kai Havertz den Laufweg macht. Ganz uneitel. Der zieht durch, macht damit die Räume auf. Der ist jederzeit gegen so ein tiefes Team als Neuner denkbar, weil er echt ein gutes Kopfballspiel hat, weil er für lange Bälle anspielbar ist, weil er permanent die Läufe alle macht. Er kann aber auch gegen richtig gute Defensiven, wie zum Beispiel für Eickaap gegen Liverpool, kriegt das hin, dass er die ganze Defensive beschäftigt. Er macht dann nicht die fünf Tore, die er hätte machen müssen, aber er beschäftigt sie. Der spielt Neuner, der spielt Achter, der spielt manchmal Sechser, wenn er zufallen hat. Der spielt Zehner, der macht alles für die Truppe und er macht es, finde ich, sogar ganz gut. Nur erkennt man es halt nicht immer gleich auf den ersten und manchmal auch noch nicht mal auf den zweiten Blick, sondern oft erst auf den dritten, aber er macht sie die Dinge und erzählt halt zu den Fußballern, da kann man das nicht so gut messen, was er der Mannschaft bringt. Und ich würde auch noch nicht sagen, dass der bei 100 Prozent ist von dem, was wir gedacht haben, dass er da hinbringt, aber er ist nicht bei 0 Prozent, so wie ich manchmal medial den Eindruck bekomme.
Ich habe tatsächlich die Beobachtung auch gemacht. Ich gucke ja selten noch privat in der Freizeit Fußball und das Arsenal-Spiel habe ich auch angeguckt. Und ich dachte mir, das haben eigentlich alle Leute für ein Problem mit Kai Harvards.
Ja, und ich fand es interessant zu hören, dass er auch sehr guter Neuner sein kann. Immer wenn in der Nationalelf Kai Harvards da mal gespielt hat, dann heißt es, oh, Notlösung, jetzt versuchen sie wieder hier. Mensch, wir brauchen doch den 2-Meter-Stürmer. Da scheint man unterschiedliche Perspektiven aufhören zu können.
Sein Problem wahrscheinlich, dass er überall ganz gut ist, aber keine Position hat, wo er wirklich super Durchschlagskraft hat. Wobei ich ihn auch als Spieler unwahrscheinlich gerne in meinem Team haben würde. Also ich bin auch echt ein Fanboy von ihm, aber irgendwie ist er halt überall gut. Aber nicht so, irgendwo fehlt es halt dann die paar Prozentpunkte auf einer Position, wo er sich dann wirklich herausstechen würde.
Uli, du siehst, wir haben weiter diskutiert, während du wegwachst. Ist das denn eine adäquate Einschätzung von Fabian deiner Meinung nach?
Ich finde schon, dass er als falsche Neun seine beste Position ist. Und das ist auch relativ klar so. Jetzt hat er halt aber den Vorteil, dass er anderswo hinrücken kann. Aber ich finde schon, dass es die Position gibt grundsätzlich. Ob es die im System immer gibt, ist die andere Frage. Aber von den Fähigkeiten her ist er glaube ich sogar ziemlich perfekter.
Ich glaube bei uns hat er auch ein bisschen das, ich nenne es das Mesut Özil Problem.
Ja, und du musst halt gräten und du musst auch eine gewisse physische Erscheinung haben. Also da ist ja, ich meine, jetzt im Nachhinein sagen alle, ach, Philipp Lahm und so weiter. Aber das hat ja wirklich Jahrzehnte fast schon gedauert, bis der mal akzeptiert wurde auch als Führungsspieler. Und erst als er nachher in der Champions-League-Pokal und Weltmeister-Pokal in einem Kalender ja quasi, also in einem Jahrzeitraum hochgehalten hat, dann war es so, ach ja, Philipp Lahm habe ich schon immer gesehen, dass er richtig fantastisch ist. Du willst einfach kein Lauch sein in der Erscheinung, sonst wirst du nicht anerkannt. Ja, genau, deswegen mache ich diesen Podcast und musste mich sehr an YouTube gewöhnen. Aber das ist was ganz anderes, das ist was für die YouTube-Kommentare. Fabian, wer ist dein Ansagen-Hero?
Ich habe wieder einen Trainer dabei und zwar mit Garcia Pimienta, dem Trainer von Uli Las Palmas, dem Aufsteiger. Da hatte ich schon vor ein paar Monaten mal gesprochen, dass die das ganz gut machen. Das machen sie übrigens weiterhin so. Tabelle 9. Knapp nur verloren am Wochenende gegen Real Madrid. Wir haben dort 1-0 geführt. Es sah lange Zeit danach aus, als könnten sie was holen. Und der Trainer ist ziemlich spannend, wie ich finde. Er kommt, wie gesagt, aus der Schule der Katalan, vom FC Barcelona. Er hat dort die zweite Mannschaft trainiert. Auch sehr erfolgreich. Er ist danach nach Las Palmas gegangen und wurde von Laporta, vom Präsidenten vom Hof gejagt. Da gab es Missverständnisse, Ungreiftheiten, weiß ich nicht. Irgendwie Kunden, die sich nicht so gut, die beiden. Aber der ist ein Trainer, der im Vergleich zu Xavi, wenn wir jetzt die Brücke da kurz schlagen wollen, jemand, der ein taktisches Konzept hat, der ein Spielsystem hat und der ein Team, wie ein kleines Team jetzt wie Las Palmas, ziemlich weit nach vorne bringt, offensiv spielen lässt. Und muss man sagen, wird mir im Moment noch ein bisschen zu wenig gelobt.
Ding, ding, ding, ding, ding, Ding, Hat-trick! Wir haben den Las-Palmas-Hat-trick! Ich habe so sehr drauf gehofft und dann habe ich deine Nachricht gesehen und dann habe ich mir auf die Zunge gebissen, nichts zu schreiben. 14.12. MVP Kirean Rodriguez, ausgewählt von Fabian Pakulat, 16.01. Unsung Hero Alvaro Valles, der Torhüter von Las Palmas und jetzt haben wir auch den Trainer. Ich freue mich so auf den Außenverteidiger in der Nächstenkonzert. Super, ist doch schön. Las Palmas ist offenbar ein Fundus an solchen Dingen. Mario, mit was möchtest du uns überraschen?
Der Name ist jetzt, glaube ich, den hat man vielleicht schon mal gehört. Das ist Charles de Quetellare, belgischer Nationalspieler, kickt bei Atalanta Bergamo, weil er von Milan dorthin verliehen wurde. Er kam 2022 von Brügge zum AC. Knapp 37 Millionen haben gewaltig auf seine Schultern gelastet. Man spricht von sehr jungen, sensiblen Fußballspielern. Er hat viele Großchancen vergeben, hatte gute Spiele bei Milan, aber irgendwann gab es nur noch abfälliges Kopfschütteln, 40 Pflichtspiele, nur eine Torvorlage. Dann eben jetzt die Laie und bei Atalanta blühte er auf. Das freut mich für ihn wirklich sehr, weil man es ihm angesehen hat, wie er zu kämpfen hatte in Mailand. 25 Spiele wettbewerbsübergreifend, 7 Tore, 7 Vorlagen. 2 davon jetzt am Wochenende beim 2-0-Erfolg über Udinese Calcio. Das sollte einmal gewürdigt werden an dieser Stelle, dass der sich rausgekämpft hat aus seinem Loch bei Mailand. Genau wie Atalanta, Spaß macht es auf jeden Fall.
Absolut. Atalanta damit auf Rang 4 jetzt gesprungen durch so einen Lauf in den letzten Partien. Wenn wir dann schon Milan mitentwint haben, dann lass doch noch schnell deinen Moment des Spieltags abfrühstücken.
Genau, kann man sogar auch mit Udinese verbinden, nämlich vor zwei Wochen ist mal wieder in einem italienischen Stadion ein Spieler rassistisch beschimpft worden. Mike Mignard war das und jetzt am Wochenende hat Zanziro ein wirklich sehr schönes und irgendwie ergreifendes Zeichen gesetzt. Da sind überall die Lichter ausgegangen und dann wurde das Zitat von Martin Luther King eingeblendet. The darkness cannot drive out. Darkness only light can do that. Und dann sind überall die Handylichter angegangen und alle zwei Mannschaften, alle Fans, Spieler, Trainer haben applaudiert. Und ich glaube, das hat Maikman ja gut getan. Und das tut uns gut, wenn wir jede Woche wieder aufs Neue sagen, dass Rassisten keinen Platz für uns haben.
Aber absolut. Komisch, dass man es immer nochmal wieder sagen muss, aber wir tun es sehr gerne. Falls ihr dazu noch irgendwelche Fragen habt, dann hört den Beginn der Schluss – ne, nicht Schlusskonferenz, so heißt er nicht mehr – der Bundesliga-Männer-Sendung, der Analysesendung von vor zwei Wochen. Da habe ich mich auch nochmal geäußert. Fabian, was ist dein Moment des Spieltags?
Es ist ein Abschied und zwar der Abschied von der Ex-Schalker-Legende Ivan Rakitic, der den FC Sevilla verlässt.
So wird er ja immer auch in Spanien genannt, oder? Ex-Schalker-Legende.
Er ist auch Sevilla-Legende. Wahrscheinlich ist er noch mehr Sevilla-Legende als Schalker-Legende. Muss man ganz ehrlich sagen, denn er hat da glaube ich den Großteil seiner Karriere verbracht. Und er muss jetzt gehen und ich habe das Gefühl, dass er nicht ganz freiwillig gehen musste. Er geht nach Saudi-Arabien. Natürlich wird ihm das auch versüßt monetär. Aber der FC Sevilla hat auch große Probleme und auch finanzielle Probleme. Und ich glaube, der muss jetzt mehr oder weniger gehen auf seine alten Jahre. Er hat sich emotional verabschiedet auf einer Pressekonferenz. Er hat im letzten Ligaspiel nicht mehr gespielt und hat sich dann tränenreich verabschiedet. Er hat dann nochmal gesagt, er würde trotzdem seine Kinder in Sevilla bettwächen, schlafen, so ungefähr. Es war dann nicht so gesagt, aber in die Richtung geht es. Und dann waren seine Kinder zu sehen, seine Frauen, die sind alles andere als glücklich, glaube ich, über den Wechsel. Auf der anderen Seite, wie gesagt, geht es halt nach Saudi-Arabien. Da wird er jetzt für die Renten noch ein bisschen was mitnehmen. Und dann wird er vielleicht auch wieder zu Sevilla zurückkehren in eine andere Funktion. Wir werden es sehen.
Ja, als siebter oder achter Trainer vielleicht. Also für alle diejenigen, die sich gefragt haben, hat sich bei Sevilla irgendwas gebessert. Seitdem wir das letzte Mal über Sevilla gesprochen haben, die waren ja schon häufiger Thema. Nee, immer noch ganz, ganz dramatisch. Platz 16, 17 Punkte, 1 Punkt Vorsprung vor Kadis auf Rang 18. Also das ist immer noch hochpräsent bei Sevilla und jetzt dann eben ohne Ivan Raketic. Uli, du darfst jetzt den Abschluss machen. Du warst der Beginn dieser Sendung, du wirst jetzt ihr Ende sein.
Wir nehmen ja am Deadline-Day auf, das heißt vertraglich verpflichtet, dass man ohne Chelsea am Deadline-Day nicht auskommt, aber zugegebenermaßen anverwandelt. Ich mache es ganz schnell. David Nunes hat am gestrigen Mittwochabend in einem Spiel vier Mal Aluminium getroffen, das hat es so noch nicht gegeben, in der Premier League und das ist schon für sich einigermaßen zum Schmunzeln. Aber dann geht er zwei Minuten später ums Eck und macht einfach eine Vorlage dann fürs 4-1 von Luis Díaz. Das zeigt, welch grandioser Typ das ist. Und Honorable Menschen an, das ist jetzt streng genommen nicht in der Liga, aber im Pokal. Der erste Auftritt Klopps im FA Cup an der Enfield Road, das You'll Never Walk Alone und die entsprechende Reaktion da drauf, da schließt sich dann ja auch der Kreis dieser Sendung hier. Das ist schon besonders und da kann man dann auch schon nachvollziehen, warum so viele Menschen weltweit das Lied, der Verein und diese Kombination aus Lied, Verein und Trainer so bewegt.
Das ist nachvollziehbar aus meiner Sicht.
Aber absolut. Und da bist du als übertragender Sender, ich weiß nicht, ob wir da zufällig vielleicht teilnehmende Gäste hier haben, da machst du die Bäckerfausen, denkst dir, ey geil, wir durften diesen Moment haben und verbreiten. Es war wirklich ein ganz besonderer. Und wenn ihr es noch nicht gesehen habt, liebe Hörerinnen und Hörer, dann schaut es und vor allem hört es euch auf jeden Fall noch an. Ihr drei, ich danke euch sehr.
Jetzt hast du mir doch nur die Tür aufgemacht für einen weiteren Senderhinweis, weil die Franzosen heute nicht da waren. Es sind ja drei Derbys über die Ligen verteilt am Wochenende. Olympique Lyon gegen Olympique Marseille, Derby d'Italia, worüber wir gesprochen haben. Und in Madrid ist Derby auch, stimmt es, Fabian?
Richtig, das wollte ich gerade noch anfügen. Atletico Madrid, Real Madrid zum gefühlt fünften Mal in den letzten zwei Wochen.
Spielt ihr nicht so ganz rein gegeneinander?
Und die drei Derbys gibt es alle in einer Konferenz, die ich hosten darf.
Sehr gut. Jetzt sind ja wirklich alle Dinge abgefrühst. Sogar die Liga – wer hätte damit noch gedacht? Wir grüßen an alle, die mal wieder keine Zeit hatten. Aber ich bedanke mich bei euch, dass ihr Zeit hattet. Das war eine Aufnahme in vier Teilen. Wenn ihr es gemerkt habt, dann habe ich schlecht geschnitten. Ansonsten vielen, vielen Dank für eure Professionalität, für die wieder aufgenommenen Bälle. Danke an Uli Hebel, Fabian Pakulat und Mario Rieker. Danke euch drei. Und euch, liebe Hörerinnen und Hörer, danke ich für die Aufmerksamkeit. Wie alles im Rasenfunk ist, auch die Ligatur von euch finanziert. Rasenfunk.de slash supporters club. Da erfahrt ihr, wie man uns unterstützen kann. Und dort könnt ihr auch dem supporters club beitreten. Und dann könnt ihr hier nach dem Zufallsprinzip erwähnt werden. So wie das Johannes, Emmerich, Andreas, Benny, Inchka und Beite geschafft haben. Herzlichen Dank für euren Support. Und bis bald hier wieder im Rasenfunk. Macht's gut und bleibt vor allem gesund. Der Rasenfunk lebt von euren Beiträgen. Vielen Dank.